اخذنا الكاميرا لفتتني الشغله قبل شويه
هناك شاب مغربي اتى على دراجه تخيل على
دراجه هوائيه همم للوصول الى هنا لتشجيع
المنتخب المغربي هذه الدراجه
اه اوكي هذه دراجه الشاب طبعا هذه امور
المباشر الذي يحصل معنا هذه الدراجه وهو
ذهب ينتقد صور امام الملعب تخيل انه شحن
دراجته من المغرب كازابلانكا من الدار
البيضاء الى اسطنبول ومن ثم على متن همم
على متن هذه الدراجه انتقل من اسطنبول الى
هنا هذا الشاب وصل
عليكم السلام شو اسمك السلام عليكم اسمي
صلاح الدين بن نارين
بتيجي على دراجه كانت صعب الرحله ولا لا
همم صراحه رحله كانت صعبه يعني كما قلت لك
كما اقول لك انطلقش من تركيا وبالضبط من
اسطنبول وتوجهت نحو الاردن والمملكه
العربيه السعوديه
ان شاء الله يعني هناك
رحله الى مكه
افريقيا او امشي نحو اسيا بس انت خططت
لتكون مش بالمونديال بهذه الفتره توصل هنا
الى الدوحه ولا جاءت الصدف انك وصلت وقت
الموضوع يعني انا ضليت سنه ونصف وانا احضر
لهذه الرحله يعني مش فقط يعني
في الطريق لا هي كانت
مخطط لها همم مره عديمه تجارب لكي اكون
جاهز في هذه الرحله كان هناك تحضير بدني
تحضير جسدي تحضير مادي والحمد لله بعد كل
هذه المسير انا هنا في قطر نعم اذا شاهدنا
الدراجه طالب اذا سمعت هذه دراجه الشعب
كما نشاهد يحمل اشياء قليل لا يوجد الكثير
من الامتعه مع الدراجه التي هل كانت هذه
ما تحمل هنا كافيا الوصول هنا الى الماضيه
نعم همم
الاوزان يسمى تقريبا البيك باكن هو يعني
هنا بين
حاولت ان اقود همم اخذ همم
يعني
هذه هذه كثير عن جد رحله فظيعه ولكن اذا
تشاهدنا حامل انت تذكره معك بطاقه لحضور
المباراه بين المغرب واسبانيا بعد قليل
يعني الشهر عند الشاب يا طالب يقدر يوصل
هل اشتريت التذاكر هل اشتريت هذه التذكره
قبل ما تاتي او تخطط همم ما تخطط لا لانك
صار لك سنه ونص بتخطتها ما اشتريت هذه
التذكره
همم الثلاثه الاولى ولما همم يعني اخذ
المغرب مر الى الدور ثمن نهائي حصلت على
هذا التذكره التذكره عندي سؤال فطوري وراح
يكون الاخير هلا لما بدك تفوت على الملعب
تحضر المباراه شو راح تعمل بهالدرجه ثمينه
لا انت بدونها ما بتقدر تتنقل همم صراحه
لما افوت امشي اودعها هنا في مكان همم
الدراجات الان يعني قطر دوله امنه يعني
نزل دراجتك حتى ولو تمسكها مع اي مكان
يعني ولا احد يقرب يعني الحمد لله السؤال
الاخير شو اكثر صعوبه واجهتك بالرحله من
اسطنبول
كانت صعوبه يعني انا لما عرفت نفسي انني
وصلت بمرض همم الاكزيما هو مرض زفاف
اليدين
يعني همم
ونفس ثانيا كثير لاني كنت عارف بانني سوف
امر من اصعب التجارب في الطريقه